is it true Jenna Ortega came up with the
dance or is that just folklore nope
that's her dance come on the whole dance
the whole day told the whole day she
just brought it to stage one day she lit
Michael I swear to God so we so Google
muck was
so Miles had the cramps on a playlist
because we were obviously trying to
think of what the song is it wasn't
gonna be like a current pop song it had
to be something kind of classic but it
also was because it was it was coming
out yeah and so we had like okay we
haven't decided what the song's gonna be
yeah and you need the song before you
can do choreography right so finally I
just did a playlist of my own like on
Spotify and then we sat we sat with Tim
when I was like probably like 15 songs
15 yeah and there was one cramp song on
that that he liked and said oh I know
another cramp song and then he he played
gookambok yeah and we were like oh
that's the and then and then he there
was a choreographer but you know he went
to he basically went to Jenna and was
like he's like I'm sure you'll come up
with something great really yeah and
that was literally it it and then
remember you know just sort of watching
them film it and then going in and
seeing just an assembly of it the next
day with the editor and it was like this
could be like the Pulp Fiction dance
like that's what I mean Lady Gaga was
doing the day yeah I mean it was it was
incredible it was just like the perfect
you know but what was but what was you
know and then this whole like thing
Jenna didica did have covert after that
because we tested really rigorously
every day when it had the full PCR test
everyone was fully masked and then uh
because the pixels was so early if
anyone had covered they were taken
offset immediately if the test came back
in the afternoon they were taken out
immediately before anyone could get
infected because it's so minimal the
testing they can they can find the most
minimal like and social that was the day
it happened and as soon as she was
Desert positive she was taking off sets
and there was never any Jeopardy she
didn't know she had covered when she was
doing it but the fact that she
just bought it there was no we had the
cargo fudge didn't use her and it was
all her yeah because I said the next day
I guess I said the choreographer didn't
right sorry it's like that I saw the
dance like that wasn't a choreographer
right she's like no she's like I did
that I'm like okay it's incredible right
yeah it's an incredible dance the
choreographer was upset
and she's not responsible for that